[Music]
as jesse paintman uh you say [ __ ] a lot
on the show unhealthy amount have you
ever have you ever counted up how many
times in the program you've said [ __ ]
um i'm sure it's
definitely easily in the hundreds that
made it to air yeah um
has ever been a favorite uh uh because
you use [ __ ] they're different so
many in different ways
is there one [ __ ] i mean there's there
yes yes uh yeah [ __ ] magnets yeah a
good one that was a good or gatorade me
[ __ ] is also really good or this is my
own private domicile [ __ ] yes so i love
all the [ __ ] yeah
are there anything are they always
written in or are you friendly no it's
all scripted yeah yeah vince gilligan
and he loves the word did you get in
trouble if you threw an extra one in
there uh probably no i i think i've i
improv maybe one or two [ __ ] right
yeah and they probably caught him
they called you in don't ever do that
again
now does how does your i mean that's the
other thing is when you walk around i
have no one thing that people uh yell at
me but
you must have fans yelling [ __ ] at you
you just must like when you walk around
in an airport don't you have people
yelling that at you yeah they just say
hey [ __ ]
do you have any crystal meth and i don't
know i i don't i'm sorry i'm gruggy
but uh we shouldn't be here
i love someone yelling that at you at a
tsa line it's it's it's [ __ ] where's my
christmas
so many people will you please call my
wife a [ __ ] it'll make her so happy
it's ridiculous i don't know that's
fantastic it's amazing do you get on the
phone then and do yeah i'll call them
i'll call whoever they want a [ __ ]
you want me to call you a [ __ ] i'll
call you a [ __ ] that's frank you should
yeah you should you should offer that
service to people yeah a little money on
the side
you uh you are the son of a minister
yes and and so
good segway
segway
you're the son of a minister so i'm
guessing there was you probably weren't
allowed to swear i never said [ __ ]
growing up in that household no i i
wasn't sermon yeah yeah
that doesn't work no i never i never
swore i mean i had my first beer at 19 i
was living in l.a on my own at age 17.
uh i i didn't swear until maybe mid mid
20s
and i used to just say you know what f
you man
so you you say you you say f you fu and
it just doesn't have that same effect as
like you yeah yeah
okay we're ending this segment right
here
you didn't say cheese and crackers
though did you no i wish i actually had
a relative to be like cheese and
crackers
just don't say anything then if you're
going to replace them